welcome it is wonderful to have so many
parents and family members here however
you define your family we're happy to
have you here and we're happy to have
you join us for worship this sunday or
any sunday it's already been an eventful
semester here we have a new choir we
have lots of new folks it's been an
exciting time we have a great
congregation and it's just been a
pleasure it's great to have Amanda and
Caleb and the choir and wonderful music
that they provided for us today and
every Sunday it is also the semester of
when I think about a month ago they'd
set up a picnic out on old campus and
they weren't supposed to start till noon
but they started right about eleven with
the music and so the accompaniment was
call me maybe I think during the sermon
and I'm sexy and I know it during
communion such is life in a campus
church I had hoped for wonderful warm
hearted passages for today that I could
speak about family unity and all
wonderful positive things but the
Scriptures just don't go along with this
this time of year because every year at
this time we are approaching the end of
whatever gospel reading this year it's
mark and it gets too really tough stuff
as Jesus gets closer and closer to
Jerusalem in the cross last year I had
the very worst parents weekend text I
think I've ever had it was you must hate
your mother and your father if you want
to get into the kingdom of heaven this
year it's not much better because it
says if you want to enter the kingdom of
God you know it's it's harder for a rich
person to enter the kingdom of heaven
than for a camel to go through the eye
of a needle I'm sure the Yale
Development Office does not want to hear
this text this is a very privileged
community this is a place where there is
are so many resources and so much wealth
it is sometimes hard for us to hear a
text like this and not want to explain
it away and those of us who've been in
church our whole lives have heard this
text so many times that we don't really
hear what it has to say we don't really
listen to the story because we have
already have a strong sense of what
Jesus says about wealth and poverty but
I want to go back and look at it again
because I think it has something to say
not only to all of us about wealth and
poverty but also to parents especially
about that fine line between love and
judgment I don't know if you read the
newspapers this week but there was this
big survey that came out of the Pew
Research Group nothing new nothing we
hadn't heard before but somehow it got
into the press that the numbers of
religious people in America were
declining which we've known forever but
suddenly it was it was a big deal and
there the poll said that one of many
things one of the many reasons that
people were leaving the church was that
they found Christians too judgmental and
I think they're right I think oftentimes
Christians are too judgmental left right
up down sideways oftentimes seem to
think they know how other people should
live without necessarily looking at the
log in their own I but I also worried
that sometimes people will take the
heart out of Christianity by trying to
make it Pleasant by trying to make it
all things to all people by trying to
make it always comfort and never
challenge we see it in this passage
today because Jesus judges yes Jesus is
forgiving but Jesus judges a lot of the
time listen to that passage that we
heard Jesus comes out and says I look at
your life and I see a deficiency what
makes Jesus different from us as
Christians though is Jesus is the only
Christian I've ever heard of that can
somehow love people and judge them at
the same time so often when we as
Christians judge other people as being
unchristian or immoral we stop loving
them at that point they've become other
or they become out
side and I think that's part of the
problem but back to the text i can
imagine this original story being read
or i can imagine even here and i can see
parents clapping their hands over their
children's ears as this passage is red
because what do parents really want for
their children they want health they
want happiness but above all they want
security they want you to get a good job
I'm sorry to say that's their goal they
want you well perhaps they want you to
support them in the retirement but
that's a whole other thing they want you
to be secure they want you to succeed so
that you never have to worry as they
might have worried in their lives so
when they hear the story about a man
coming up to Jesus and asking what do I
need to be closer to God what do I need
to be in God's kingdom I can imagine his
parents standing at the back of the
crowd of the parents of this man they're
saying good good good he's asking a
religious question that means he's still
religious Yale didn't wash his faith out
of him it's good and when Jesus responds
listing the commandments and the man
responds I've kept all these since I was
a child can't you see his parents just
beaming they're so happy our Little
Billy such a good boy but I can imagine
them then quickly dragging him away
don't listen to Jesus because what Jesus
says is you're almost there you've
almost got the kingdom of God all you
have to do all you have to do sell what
you own and give the money to the poor
and follow me right just one little
thing it's a scripture that has been
interpreted and misinterpreted so many
times that we have trouble hearing the
actual story and we imagine i think that
jesus is somehow judging this man or
condemning him but jesus isn't out to
get this man he does not judge him in
that way he doesn't contradict him when
he says he follows the commandments
he doesn't say he's bad or wrong in any
way in this story if you look at the
actual text in fact what it says what
mark Wright's is Jesus looking at him
loved him not in spite of who he was but
because of who he was I think when I
hear this story I imagine Jesus is
setting this guy up he's just another
fall guy just another Pharisee I can
imagine a sly grin on Jesus's face or
Jesus rolling his eyes as he says okay
Buster if you really want in get rid of
all your money but that's not this story
Jesus isn't being ironic or impossible
he's just telling this man what he needs
to do all you have to do is sell what
you own and give it to the poor and
follow me it's not meant to be a
philosophical statement it's not an
economic statement or even a theological
statement it's just a fact he's saying
to one man who sincerely wants to do
what God wants that all that stands in
your way is your possessions I think
because we love our possession so much
at least I do I don't know about you I
love my car I love my house I love my
things because we love them so much we
have trouble hearing this as just the
straightforward statement that it is you
want to enter the kingdom of God you
this person need to get rid of your
things it's scary because Jesus the Word
of God as described in Hebrews is a
sharp knife like to think of jesus as a
sharp knife Jesus the word cuts it says
like a scalpel it separates our good
intentions from our actual deeds it
separates the me I tell myself i am from
the me i actually am it separates my
excuses from my intention the Word of
God is not like many of you parents
whose love means protecting your
children from hard messages right you're
there as the buffer from a hard
world you're the one that said honey
perhaps not ballet maybe women's rugby
some perhaps not the oboe maybe the
tambourine Jesus has to tell us the
truth though he's not there to protect
us because he's thinking of the bigger
picture of our life not just protecting
us in the moment he can't let this man
whom he loves go on believing that he's
getting closer to God when his
possessions stand in his way Jesus tells
him the truth Jesus honors him by
inviting him in by recognizing his faith
and telling him how close he is you're
almost there but then has to point out
the truth Jesus doesn't say if you
notice why he has to sell all his
possessions but these possessions
clearly stand between this man and God
perhaps without even knowing it this man
has let himself be defined by what he
owns for some people the desire to have
more things I think comes from a kind of
insecurity gathering more things gives
us a sense of solidity of reality I am
the person who owns this house I am the
person who has this business I am the
person who has this beautiful car and I
do love my car I am the person who has
this Yale education I am the person who
has this wonderful job but sometimes
maintaining my possessions or my status
becomes who I am I love my things so I
have to protect my things I can begin to
imagine that there are people out there
who want to take away my things there
are people out there who don't
understand how important my things are
how much my things are a part of me and
I need to build a wall to keep those
people out and gather inside with others
like me who have wonderful things
eventually I may have to take
pre-emptive action against those people
who might want to take away my things
too
sure they're never able to I won't talk
about the election that's my word it's
the exact opposite of the biblical law
and the prophets who taught that
blessings are to be shared with the
widows and the orphans the strangers and
the outcasts what I love my things so
much I say to myself I will harvest even
the corners of my fields if I want
because they are my fields somehow for
some people possessions themselves
determine what is moral I become the
author of my own story and God is
written out except as some remote
provider of blessings but don't let
yourself off too easy undergraduates I
know you have no money it's not just
possessions that can stand between us in
the kingdom I imagine that if any one of
us including me were to kneel at Jesus's
feet as this man does and ask him what
do I need to live god's way he would
commend us on what we've already done he
would look at us deeply and he would
love us and then he would say he lacked
just one thing and Jesus would ask us I
think to give up that one thing that
impedes our faith that one thing that we
hold to so tightly that it defines us my
intelligence my work ethic my
accomplishments my service to others my
faith my family my athletic skill my
voice my wealth the list can go on in
her evening prayer reflection this past
Wednesday shall see to told the story I
will adapt to a different theme she
wrote a beautiful passage about our body
as what defines us she wrote a few years
ago I was in the hospital about to go
into surgery and I was lying there in
bed being wheeled away from my family
towards the anesthesia board and I felt
that my identity was falling away from
me I none of the possessions and
accessories that make me feel so safe my
clothes my jewelry my watch my purse I
had no friends or friends family around
me to affirm that I was a person who
loved
and mattered I didn't even have a book
or an iPod to distract me from the fact
that I was about to go through a surgery
all I had was a hospital gown a plastic
ID bracelet and an IV in my arm none of
which belonged to me and none of which
brought me any comfort shall story
captures so well the delicate nature of
our identities as we construct them
they're like castles built of feathers I
think I know who I am but my identity is
actually a random assemblage of every
compliment I've ever received every
behavior that was positively reinforced
every possession I had that others
admired every myth I've made up about
myself to avoid humiliation Jesus
however looks at us and with ultimate
love judges us judges what we're holding
on to he sees through us like glass he's
the only person truly capable of both
judging and loving at the same time and
Jesus looks at us and loves us and said
you just have to give up one thing one
thing that stands between you and God
because Jesus loves us and knows that
all the things all the things we cling
to the things that we let define us are
not able to bear the weight that we put
on them Jesus looks ahead and he sees
the day when that one thing will fail us
when families break up when loved ones
die when we hit that failure that big
failure of our lives when wealth
disappears in a mortgage-backed
conflagration Jesus looks at us and
loves us and says loosen your grasp
father John Shea quotes this great story
by Anthony damela who said in the
nineteenth century there was a tourist
from the u.s. visiting a famous polish
rabbi named Hafez hyeme the tourist was
astonished to see that the famous rabbis
home was just a simple room filled with
books the only furniture was a rude
table and bench the tourists asked the
rabbi
where is your furniture and the rabbi
replied where is yours torres said mine
but i'm only a visitor here the rabbi
said so am i Jesus says loosen your grip
I can see you parents wanting to stick
your fingers in your students ears right
now no no no my daughter is supposed to
be here at Yale to achieve to get a good
job to meet a nice partner to make her
mark on the world give her a chance to
build up an identity that so that she
can decide what's important but if we're
really made by God led by God protected
by God assured of eternal life we lose
the need to impress ourselves on the
world to make our mark which is always
an act of violence which is always
somehow about fear Jesus wants to set us
free from the things that bind us even
though we love them and even though we
believe they tell us who we are the
things I love more than God need to
become the things I love because god has
loaned them to me for a moment Jesus
wants to remind us San Teresa says that
God is enough God is enough amen
you